Hello, this is Ann, certified nutritionist and genetic specialist with Connors Clinic.
And today we're going to be talking about acetylcholine.
So what is acetylcholine and why is it important?
Acetylcholine is the most plentiful neurotransmitter in the human body.
It's the neurotransmitter that sends signals to our muscles so they can activate and move
our bodies.
And it's also a neurotransmitter that is essential for brain health because of its involvement
in thought, learning, and memory.
It's so important for our brains that the deficit of acetylcholine is linked to Alzheimer's
disease.
It's the neurotransmitter that actually tells the hippocampus to store a memory.
Acetylcholine is made in our neurons and the nutrient colon is required for its production.
You can get colon in the foods that you eat like eggs and meat and your body can also
make colon by way of the PEMT gene.
And there's two things that influence the PEMT gene.
First is estrogen, the hormone estrogen, and the second is variance in the PEMT gene.
So estrogen is what's going to turn on the PEMT gene and then variance in the PEMT make
it so that the gene is not working to its full potential.
So if you have low estrogen and or variance in the PEMT gene, then your body is not producing
enough colon, which then obviously can lead to low acetylcholine production.
I think it's also important to note that there are studies that show that high intake of
colon by pregnant women results in higher cognitive performance of the developing child for
his, his or her entire life.
And it really can reduce the risk of that child ever developing dementia later in life.
So it's super important for pregnant women to take colon for obviously brain health for
their developing babies.
And it's also really important for vegans to supplement with colon since the foods that
are highest sources of colon tend to be animal products.
These are some of the supplements that we offer here at Conor's Clinic that will support
your production of colon and acetylcholine.
If you'd like to learn more about these products or even learn more about our genetic plan,
you can schedule a complimentary 15-minute consultation with me.
You can call the clinic to schedule that or you can schedule directly online through
my calendar.
Hopefully, this was helpful and I look forward to potentially working with you in more
depth.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.